foreign
[Music]
the transcended immediate presence of
the self-conscious Essence has the form
of universal self-consciousness this
notion of the transcended individual
self that is absolute being immediately
expresses therefore the establishing of
a community which carrying hitherto in
the sphere of picture thinking now
returns into itself as the self and in
doing this Spirit passes over from the
second element constituting it that is
from picture thinking into the third
element self-consciousness as such
if we further consider the behavior of
picture thinking in its progress we find
first of all the Declaration that the
Divine being takes on human nature here
it is already asserted that in
themselves the two are not separate
likewise in the Declaration that the
Divine being from the beginning
externalizes itself that its existence
withdraws into itself and becomes
self-centered and evil implies though it
does not expressly assert that this evil
existence is not in itself something
alien to the Divine being
absolute being would be but an empty
name if in truth there were for it and
other if there were a fall from it on
the contrary the moment of being within
self constitutes the essential moment of
the self as spirit
that this being within self and the
actuality which follows from it belong
to Absolute being itself this which for
us is notion and insofar as it is notion
appears to the picture thinking
Consciousness as an incomprehensible
happening
the in itself assumes for it the form of
indifferent being the thought that these
moments of absolute being and of the
self-centered self which seem to flee
from each other are not separate also
appears in this picture thinking for it
does it does possess the true content
but this picture thought comes later in
the externalization of the Divine being
who is made flesh
the picture thought is in this way still
immediate and therefore not spiritual it
knows the human form of the Divine being
at first only as a particular not yet as
a universal form it becomes spiritual
for this Consciousness in the movement
whereby this Divine being in human shape
sacrifices his immediate exist existence
again and returns to the Divine being
only when Essence is reflected into
itself is its spirit in this picture
thought there is depicted the
reconciliation of the Divine being with
its other in general and specifically
with the thought of it evil
if this reconciliation is notionally
expressed by saying that it consists in
the fact that evil is in itself the same
as goodness or again that the Divine
being is the same as nature and its
whole extent or that nature separated
from the Divine being is simply nothing
we must regard this as an unspiritual
way of talking and one that is
necessarily bound to give rise to
misunderstandings if evil is the same as
goodness then evil is just not evil nor
goodness good on the contrary both are
suspended moments evil in general is
self-centered being for self and
goodness is what is simple and without
itself
paragraph
780 is one of the longest in hadel's
phenomenology of spirit
indeed you might say it's over long for
a single paragraph if you think about
what a paragraph typically is you know a
consistent development of thought
there's so much going on in here over
the two pages in the Miller translation
that it's just not going to all be
coverable in the depth that we want to
go into
in a single installation of this
commentary so we're breaking it into two
different portions of the same paragraph
with the hinge between them being the
place where Hegel says if evil is the
same as goodness then evil is just not
evil nor goodness good on the contrary
both are suspended moments evil in
general is self-centered being for self
and goodness is what is simple and
without a self so we're gonna go that
far in this one and then we'll pick up
at that point in the next one and
hopefully manage to pack all of this
into the normal scope of these
commentaries so that said uh what is
going on in here we are coming off of a
as I mentioned in the previous one a
very metaphysical and Abstract but very
important hinge paragraph and now we're
getting Good and Evil coming back up for
discussion but there's a even bigger
contrast that is rearing its head very
explicitly and which we're going to see
some some development taking place
within this this paragraph 780 and that
is the distinction that Hegel makes
consistently throughout his works but
very much so it in terms of religion and
the relation between religion and
philosophy or absolute knowledge that
we're heading towards and that is
between picture thinking as it's being
translated here a representation is a
broader term that gets used for stellon
right and this is uh not a bad thing for
Hegel uh being represented or pictured
or imagined this is very important right
but it's not the full development of
what Hegel is going to call the the
notion or concept the gif
and here it's going to be
self-consciousness as such that gets
associated with it and there's a lot to
say about that but
let's start at the very beginning
with the text he tells us the
Transcendent that's Alpha Hoban
immediate presence of the self-conscious
Essence now presence gagenvark could be
also translated as present there's a
temporal Dimension to it the
Transcendent immediate presence of the
self-conscious Essence the vision has
the form of universal
self-consciousness so we're seeing
self-consciousness is important in this
discussion right and there's a lot to
say about it but I do want to point out
universal self-consciousness where do we
find Universal self-consciousness I mean
we could say well we find it within
ourselves and if you think about the way
that people often proceeded in
philosophy in the modern period it was
by looking within to themselves to their
own experience even the empiricists you
know like Hume especially would do this
you know I am the universal
self-consciousness and this leads us
into Kant and this leads us into other
thinkers uh later on but maybe we find
the universal self-consciousness the
oligomina not just within our own
purview but within something that
situates us exceeds us
a other kind of minor right uh in this
case uh geminda the community as it's
being translated here so he says the
notion the concept of the transcended
individual self that is absolute being
immediately expresses therefore what the
establishing of a community and now
notice establishing
constitutierreon right there's a lot of
German words that Hegel could have used
here instead he uses this rather
latinate technical term that typically
refers to institutions to politics to
the sphere in which people are making
deliberate Arrangements uh establishing
things setting things up and what is
being set up here
a community like a minda a religious
community what we've been talking about
for such a long time in the religion
section and even before it to some
degree insofar as religion entered in
insofar as a religion has something that
is social which is generally how
religion finds itself it's only really
in eccentric people and in in you know
modernity that we find religion being
this totally individualized matter but
that's a topic for another time so
we're going to come back to the
self-consciousness thing but I do want
to go on a little bit with this sentence
now notice the next thing which he says
the establishing of a community which
carrying
for violin
a hitherto in the sphere of picture
thinking now returns into itself as the
self and in doing this spirit and we'll
talk about these elements so it returns
into itself before it was
carrying messing around you know trying
to hang out and do what it's going to do
in the realm of four stellen it is
picturing not only itself to itself but
also the religious object the Divine to
it and its relation to the divine all
these things are being expressed in what
we can call picture language in in
representation and this is going to take
a number of determinate forms as we've
already seen for example the Incarnation
now going back a little bit so we've got
the self-conscious Essence the universal
self-consciousness right and why are we
talking so much about self-consciousness
and why are we going to be figuring the
notion as self-consciousness as such Why
is self-consciousness assuming such an
important role didn't we didn't we leave
this behind us a long time ago in the
self-consciousness section well remind
ourselves that at uh there's two ways
early on in the religion section that
self-consciousness is going to be
thematized as Central one of which is
talking about the previous sections you
have Consciousness self-consciousness
reason and spirit and these are all more
and more concrete and as we go through
the book more and more complex and
lengthy discussions that Hegel figures
as threads feeding into religion as a
kind of you know bringing all of them
together like a knot but even more
importantly
Consciousness and self-consciousness are
being their relations are being worked
out
through the religion section we need to
bring these two back together again and
it takes you know a lot of different
forms not all of which are successful so
let's let's go on he talks about passing
over from the second element
constituting it that is picture thinking
this is Spirit into the third element
self-consciousness as such right so he
doesn't say the concept the notion but
self-consciousness as such what do we
know about self-consciousness uh well by
the way self-conscious is such all the
zolke right so not Uber helped or
anything like that but
um what do we know about it well you
know self-consciousness exists in
relation to other self-consciousnesses
they are looking for a recognition on
air cannon
um you know self-consciousness involves
a lack a desire a geared a hunger for or
you know what it is that others can give
to it all of this is important here all
of this is part of
the notion
but in a complicated way that's not
immediately apparent so he goes on and
he says
if we further consider the behavior of
picture thinking in its progress now
this is very important picture thinking
has in fact been making some progress a
fort gang in in hegel's German right it
is it is going further it is going
Beyond
and it's making progress you could say
in two different complementary ways one
of which is adequate to what it is that
it's trying to you know get at leaving
picture thinking behind the other of
which occurs within the scope of picture
thinking so it can make progress by
developing better and better for stancen
better and better representations or
pictures of things but it can also
attempt to progress by moving beyond
itself into this third element
self-consciousness as such or the notion
and he says if we consider this we find
first of all and here we're going to get
to a couple different things that
picture thinking is saying about human
beings and the Divine and we can see a
contrast between what picture thinking
can give us and what the the notion or
self-consciousness trying to work this
out in a more abstract and also at the
same time uh developed you know
transcended way is going to tell us so
he says we find first of all the
Declaration the Divine being takes on
human nature okay the Incarnation right
so here we're very clearly talking about
the Christian uh conception we'll say so
we can avoid the words notion or concept
of the Incarnation and how is this going
to be made sense of how is it
significant applicants grasped he says
here
it is already asserted that in
themselves the two are not separate
likewise in the Declaration that the
Divine being from the beginning
externalizes itself that its existence
withdraws into itself and becomes
self-centered and evil though it does
not expressively assert that this evil
existence is not in itself something
alien to the Divine being so a good bit
of you know theology going on there
where's this happening
it's not happening although you might
you know in the first read think that
this is happening on the side of picture
thinking picture thinking starts out
with Divine being takes on human nature
and a you know let's call it transcended
viewpoint on this tells us that among
other things
um in themselves the two human and
divine are not separate
the Divine being from the beginning
externalizes itself
its existence withdraws into itself and
becomes self-centered and and evil right
um whatever evil is going to mean here
so instead of saying well at a given
point of time this baby was born and
other come the Magi and Bethlehem and
donkeys and all the crash stuff and then
you know we lose track of this kid for a
while until in one of the gospels he's
he's you know left behind and hanging
out in his father's house and then you
know fast forward to his ministry and
all of this sort of stuff and then
crucifixion then you know resurrection
and boom Community well okay that's a
story but theologically
you can say you know from a hegelian
perspective
that was always going to happen
that's not something that just like boom
you know popped into existence because
God around uh they were being very
anachronistic around 80 zero or you know
BC zero of course because these These
are referring to anno domini year of the
Lord and before Christ right
um
God said well
ah these Jewish people are having a
rough time let me send the Messiah or
something like that no no that's that's
not what's going on from the side of
um the concept or the third element
right
he goes on and he says this evil
existence is not itself something alien
to the Divine being that's something
that uh picture thinking has a hard time
making sense out of and then he says
absolute being would be but an empty
name if in truth there were for it and
other if there were a fall from it on
the contrary the moment of being within
self in zigzign
constitutes he says the essential moment
of the self of spirit
so that's a pretty intensified thing
this not just Spirit you know Geist but
the self of spirit the zebs of of Geist
right so being within self is something
that we can grasp conceptually
but we can't really represent adequately
in terms of picture thinking and here we
might also remind ourselves that later
on in the philosophy of religion Hegel
is going to express his concerns about
Reliance not just upon for Stellar as
like you know imagination or picture
thinking you know schematic
representations but also what he calls
the philosophy of the understanding as
opposed to the you know conceptual
philosophy right there's certain ways of
doing philosophy which are much more
like picture thinking and are not going
to be helpful here so he goes on and he
says
um
that is being within self in the in the
design right as opposed to anzacson and
the actuality of the vehicle which
follows from it belonged to Absolute
being itself
this which for us is notion it insofar
as it is notion when it when it tries to
translate back into picture thinking
what do we get here he calls it an
incomprehensible happening I guess Shane
it happens at some point in stories or
history or something like that now the
incomprehensible is very funny here
because this is almost like a tautology
if you think about it isn't it because
it's in the the German it's
right uh literally
unconceptual
and well of course it's unconceptual
because it's we're moving from the big
riff back into picture thinking and
we've gotten much richer much more
Dynamic understanding of things and then
we try to put it in picture thinking and
it doesn't really come across well so he
says the in itself assumes the form of
indifferent being
the thought that those moments of
absolute being of the self-centered
itself which seem to flee from each
other are not separate this also appears
in picture thinking and here he says
something really interesting
where it does possess the true content
the in halt but this picture thought
comes later in the externalization
of the Divine being who is made flesh
the picture thought is in this way still
immediate
unmediated and therefore not spiritual
how so it knows the human form of the
Divine being at first only as a
particular not yet as a universal form
so it knows you know in this happening
uh it knows Jesus as the person who's uh
you know surrounded by a whole Community
he draws to himself in opposition to the
established authorities of various sorts
people don't know what to make of him
there's a whole cool story actually
stories that can be told about him but
it doesn't have Universal
form yet he says it becomes spiritual
for this Consciousness in the movement
where thereby the Divine being in human
shape
sacrifices his immediate existence and
again returns to the Divine being only
when Essence is reflected into itself is
its spirit so what are we what are we
saying we're supposed to move from a you
know developed but still in some
respects rudimentary and primitive
understanding of what the significance
of
of this Jesus person in his community is
to something that is transformed the
Transcendent sublated you know Alpha
hoben into a concept
now he goes on and he says
um in this picture thought there is
depicted and here we have a second thing
that a second set of things rather that
that we go from representation picture
thinking into the concept and we see
that you know we've got more to work
with as a result so what is it in this
picture thought there's the depicted the
reconciliation the Pharaoh zunong of
what the uh the Divine being with its
other
okay so it's other in general it's
Andres Uber helped
and let's pause for just a second a
little bit earlier Hegel had pointed out
that if you like really really think it
through
absolute being would be as he says an
empty name if in truth there were for it
and other there can't really be an other
to Absolute being
in a genuine sense because everything
has to be an absolute being doesn't it
it has to be encompassed by it if there
could be a again he says a fall from it
as picture thinking depicts as we've
talked about in the previous paragraphs
so coming back to this in picture
thought we have the reconciliation of
the Divine being with its other in
general and specifically so we're no
longer just in general we're getting uh
we're getting specific we're getting
particular right with the thought of it
as we saw in the previous paragraphs the
thought of it evil bosom and can this be
part of absolute being it has to be but
how do we picture that to ourselves well
here's where it gets really really
interesting so Hegel goes on and he says
um
if this reconciliation is notionally
expressed right literally not notionally
expressed
as concept
if it's actually going to be
you know conceptualized we could say we
say that it consists in the fact that
evil is itself the same as goodness
okay you might say well that's not going
to work you can see kind of look ahead
you've read the paragraph already
let's just go with this for a minute so
evil is itself the same as goodness
um and uh what else the Divine being is
the same as nature in its whole extent
right and it's gansa um and how it's How
nature is grasped and as a totality and
notice we've got these two words same
same
right they're actually the same same as
each other there's a kind of identity
statement going on there or at least a
this is just you know this reduces to to
this so we've got evil it's all same as
goodness Divine being same as nature and
its full extent and then what do we have
a a third assertion nature separated
from the Divine being is simply nothing
and this is interesting because he he
actually says it's
the nothing right uh Das Nix right he
could have just said NYX right
um but he's he calls it nature separate
it is the nothing it doesn't really
follow that up and I don't think that we
have to follow that up but it's an
interesting thing to note now you could
say well
that's what we got from moving from
picture thinking which okay it's got its
problems but now we're in the notion and
we're saying yeah Evil's just the same
as goodness and the Divine is the same
as nature and nature is you know nothing
without the Divine being you might be
like well hey I I don't really want to
go there then because this seems really
dry abstract and probably unhelpful it's
one of those things where you're like
well hell everything's the Divine being
then and you notice that there's this
illusion of value this Erasure that's
going on evil it's just the same thing
as goodness who cares right everything
does become arbitrary indifferent at
that point in time and so notice what he
says at the next point
we must regard this as an unspiritual
way of talking and way of talking here
is actually you know concealing the fact
that it's Zeke austral right so it's a
it's a unspiritual way for a person or a
mind to express themselves Express their
understanding Express their relation
Express where they fit in so this isn't
the genuine notion uh and what it yields
this is how picture thinking may be
grasps it right and so he says we must
regard this is an unspiritual way of
talking
one necessarily bound you know uh note
vendig to give rise to miss under
standings and here he's going to then
and we're going to close out by talking
about those misunderstandings if evil is
the same as goodness then evil is just
not evil nor goodness good right we've
got uh again an Erasure of value
everything is made to go back to a
previous paragraph like gutig of equal
value of you know equal worth but it's
not evil there's something different
from goodness and evil and he says on
the contrary both of these and here he's
telling us you know what evil and good
are at this point again he's talked
about this before as well
um on the contrary both are suspended
moments evil in general is
self-centered being for self goodness is
what is simple and without a self now
that's not an adequate way of framing it
either
um especially the you know the goodness
part goodness is what lacks a self
um so
you know nobody has goodness no nobody
who's a somebody has goodness well that
would be a big problem that is not
actually hegel's position of course but
what we're seeing here is the attempts
to move from picture thinking into the
concept are not quite so simple and
straightforward it's just like flipping
a switch or saying aha I've got a you
know aha moment some sort of immediate
Enlightenment no there's there's a lot
of work
involved in making sense of this and
this is a good place for us to stop here
in this paragraph and let it sink in
before we make yet another big effort to
push through the remaining half of
paragraph 780.